martin jol their sociologue et membre du
parti
d-link et c'est notre rubrique vu de
l'extérieur ce soir bonsoir martin dans
les airs merci d'être avec nous en
direct sur rt france petite réaction
tout d'abord à ce qu'on vient d'entendre
des français apparemment insulté le
ministre des finances qui présente ses
excuses une réaction de votre côté
effectivement et c'est une bonne chose
que ça suffisait car il ne faut pas en
force et les nationalismes qui que nous
soyons en période de crise ou non cela
ne peut pas être exposés les identités
nationales force certaine personne à
blâmer d'autres pour cette maladie
alors c'est vrai que l'allemagne fait
figure d'exemple un lan man qui
respectent les consignes de confinement
qui semble parfois il est vrai faire
mieux que nous notamment sur le bilan la
manière de traiter l'épidémie alors je
me pose la question ce soir selon vous
qu'est ce que vous faites mieux vous les
allemands que nous à les français dans
la gestion de cette épidémie
je ne pense pas que nous fassions quoi
que ce soit de mieux au niveau de la
gestion de l'épidémie
crise est très plurielle il ya beaucoup
de sujets différents qu'il faut traiter
afin d'analyser les raisons pour
laquelle dans un pays pour y voir plus
de contamination d'autres par exemple
une promiscuité plus grande entre
personnes âgées et personnes jeunes ou
nombre de personnes qui sont vulnérables
face au virus
en allemagne nous avons des manières d
méthode de décompte différentes par
exemple nous ne comptons dans certaines
régions les morts que si le combat virus
est la cause de mort avéré alors que
dans d'autre ne compte
on ne compte pas s'y est la personne
serait morte toute façon donc il est
difficile de dire en ce moment si un
pays s'en tire mieux qu'un autre
bon c'est vrai que je joue beaucoup de
matchs dans le vert mais on nous
présente l'allemagne comme cinq fois
moins de morts qu'en france vous vous
remettez peut-être en compte le comptage
tout simplement de des morts liés aux
coronavirus s'expliquerait cette
disparité entre les deux bilans
selon vous ce n'est pas la seule raison
il y a beaucoup de cause ces différentes
ci pourrait avoir beaucoup de raisons
mais cela pourrait en être une
il pourrait également y avoir des
raisons liées à la façon dont les
personnes mènent leur vie quotidienne
dont les hôpitaux sont construits par
exemple en italie beaucoup de personnes
contaminées par le coronavirus visé
vivait
dans des conditions très polluée donc
ils ont été frappés plus durement par le
virus que d'autres personnes dans
d'autres environnements
si les hôpitaux sont bien situées si ils
n'ont pas trop souffert de politique qui
alors c'est mieux que d autres régions
les hôpitaux sont bien financés
il ya donc beaucoup de raisons il s'agit
là que de spéculations n'ont pas
vraiment dire qu'un pays s'en tire bien
mieux qu'un autre ou pourquoi surtout il
y a tant de raisons qui pourraient
l'expliquer que nous ne connaissons bras
donc il faudrait maintenant plutôt
étudier la crise et non pas au niveau
national ce n'est pas l'important
l'important c'est que dans une telle
crise
il faudrait comprendre que le
capitalisme néolibéral nous amener dans
cette crise c'est une crise capitaliste
construite s'est effondré en janvier et
nous sommes maintenant dans une crise
économique car le coronavirus cause
encore d'autres problèmes il faut
observer qui se servent de cette
pandémie et de quelle façon que vous
expliquer je me demandais en quoi c'est
une crise liée au capitalisme selon vous
parce que des épidémies
malheureusement l'histoire on a eu plein
on n'était pas encore dans un processus
capitaliste en quoi c'est une crise
capitaliste selon vous pardonnez moi de
vous avoir coupé mais c'est important de
vous poser la question quand même le
virus lui-même n'est pas causée par le
capitalisme mais les circonstances de la
gestion de crise pourrait être
différente par exemple si et tous les
hôpitaux
tous ces hôpitaux n'est pas été
privatisée alors s'il n'y avait pas
autant d'exportation
de d'équipements médicaux seraient
nécessaires il n'y aurait pas
d'exclusion de certaines personnes des
systèmes de soins comme cela existe aux
états unis si l'état prenait en charge
le système de santé bien plus que dans
les pays néolibéraux les résultats ne
seraient donc pas aussi grave
je pense que si l'on observe le virus on
peut voir la façon dont les gens se
servent du virus par exemple l'un de mes
amis a dû se rendre au travail tous les
matins en bus une demi heure à l'aller
une demi-heure retour et dans le but
bien sûr les gens se tiennent très
proches les uns des autres et il n'est
pas nécessaire n'était pas une serre
convient de se rendre au travail
même ses chefs lui disait de rester chez
lui mais la compagnie les supérieurs
disait qu'il fallait continuer à
travailler et cela est vraiment
incohérent si on veut gérer une crise
convenablement
il faut comprendre pourquoi est il
possible dans certaines régions de la
société est de rester le travail et tant
d'autres non si les gens restent
éloignés de 1 mètre 50
alors il est possible de nous contaminer
personne mais si l'on prend le bus là où
on est écartée que de 30 à 40 cm alors
il peut y avoir une propagation en plus
importante
il faudrait observer ce qui se passe et
comprendre pourquoi ce virus se
développe ainsi il faut aider les
personnes exclues
il faut découvrir ce qui est nécessaire
afin d'empêcher la propagation du virus
mais il faut également être très clair
sur les personnes qui meurent par
exemple en allemagne en 2013
il ya une épidémie de grippe elle
quarante mille personnes
morte en six mois le cours n'a virus et
une pandémie et beaucoup de personnes
sont mortes également et chaque mort est
de trop donc effectivement il faut
prévenir il faut également comprendre
pourquoi certaines personnes sont
touchées et pas d'autres pourquoi nous
la gérons de cette façon pourquoi de
telles mesures incohérentes sont mises
en place et ensuite avec un budget
général on pourra prévenir la
propagation du virus
ou alors on pourra en tout cas essayer
d'encourager certaines personnes plus
vulnérables
donc nous devons être très prudents afin
que ce virus ne permettent pas d'élargir
encore le fossé entre pauvres et riches
merci beaucoup martin a dans le vert
sociologue et membre du parti die linke